[Music]
aspirin or de las autoridades Colombia
nos vamos la bienvenida al Centro
attention integral ah nuestra MBA
especially y'know estra our Tacoma
Sanada at Ulta Kelly Clement
una información Lambie a special
Valliere une una declaración después de
sabah a continuous ubi sita cone
familias que estan aloha hosaka nlk a a
possibly hasta commission ala al Kunta
yell representante the ignorant Columbia
muchas gracias the rural power up
against two seminaries the commensal ah
in 2000
I was in Ecuador visiting some of the
many Colombians who had fled the
conflict I said to the families that I
had met via itself and peace made it
possible to return home and today I have
met returning Colombian refugees but not
for the reasons I had hoped
over 400,000 Colombians who had been
displaced in Venezuela had now been
forced to return by the has they are
alongside 1.3 billion Venezuelan
refugees who have sought protection in
Colombia in addition 3.3 million
Venezuelan nationals are crossing the
border for short periods of time to find
supplies and basic assistance the impact
on public services here in Colombia is
staggering some border hospitals are now
providing emergency health care to as
many Venezuelans as Colombia's many
schools have doubled the number of
students in their classrooms but
Colombia still has kept its borders open
and is doing everything it can to absorb
these unprecedented numbers of desperate
people is no displacement all too well
this country has experienced 15 or its
peace agreement is less than three years
old and fragile it is extraordinary that
a country facing so many huge challenges
of its own has shown such Humanity and
is making these life-saving efforts
I want to I want to acknowledge the
bravery strength and resilience
of the Colombian people the situation in
Bolivia and in Peru and Ecuador puts the
debate and rhetoric on refugee issues in
many peaceful countries including my own
humble in context despite what that
political rhetoric often implies less
than 1% of all refugees are resettled in
Western nations the vast majority of the
world's uprooted people are displaced
within their or it crossed into
neighboring countries like Colombia
[Music]
it seems that often those who have the
least give them up humanitarian appeal
issued by UNHCR
and its partners in December last year
it's a quarter funded 21% funded to be
exact in the meantime the number of
Venezuelan refugees and migrants has
Riven risen to over 4 million this is a
life-and-death situation
for millions UNHCR has received only a
fraction of the funds it needs to do
even the bare minimum to help them
survive the countries receiving them
like Colombia are trying to manage an
unmanageable situation with insufficient
resources but neither they nor
humanitarian actors like UNHCR are
getting the funds they need in order to
keep the pace with this influx and yet
still they do everything they can this
is not only true of the Venezuela crisis
this picture of soaring numbers and
declining funds is replicated Internet
On June 20th we mark World Refugee day
UNHCR expects another significant rise
in the overall numbers of displaced
people worldwide and a fall in the
number of people being able to return
home as the vast majority of refugees I
have met longed to do instead of
focusing on how to address the gap in
see and security a piece that is causing
a number of people to move we hear
increasing talk of what individual
governments are no longer prepared to do
whether that is to receive refugees or
asylum seekers or to contribute the
funding to UN operations and appeals
with the numbers of refugees worldwide
rising so fast even at best duplicitous
at worst to present these policies as if
they were some kind of solution and your
neighbor's house is on fire you are not
safe if you simply lock your door
leadership is about taking
responsibility as generations before us
took up their responsibility to address
threats to peace and security and build
a rules-based World Order
in the mean time it is not possible to
put a value on the support that Colombia
and Peru and Ecuador are giving the
people of Venezuela because is at the
core of what it is to be human the human
response is not to turn a blind eye it
is to acknowledge your fellow men and
women and their suffering it is to work
towards above all the human response is
not to see and not to blame a victim of
war or violence for their circumstances
or for their requests to help their
defenseless children today we need more
humanity than ever
rational thinking from people who are
unafraid to take responsibility and
leadership that will be my message as I
leave Colombia and in the months to come
as I try to find
last two days I will not forget what
I've seen here I will not forget the
Venezuelan people I have met here my
hearts are with them and I hope to
return soon
[Applause]